[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to everyday I'm day we're gonna
talk about how Beyonce Shops at Target
grilled-cheese inventions but first
watch this robot on robot crime so this
video comes from yeah Las Vegas yeah
this Tesla is reading this Russian robot
looks as if almost he's like checking I
mean clearly that sweater vested man has
sex with that robot and this is like a
true crime for him we have a very
special guest today we're here with
Christie she has a show coming up it's
called it's Christie bitch will plug it
later but you should just like get
excited so how do you feel about that
[Laughter]
I'm all about destroying the smug ass
room that will be how we all die what's
so great is that it was hit by a
driverless Tesla yes that Tesla saw that
robot and was like I want to have sex
with that man and just some more
wrinkles to this there was a man inside
the Tesla car Oh said it was on
autopilot and he had nothing to do with
okay and the robot company of the robot
that died right it's a Russian company
that is tweeting at Tesla and at Elon
Musk to be like you've killed our robots
what was the robot doing there does
anyone know
[Laughter]
over previously shook hands with polling
data predicted World War II it's time
for today's video
yeah there's like Easter eggs everywhere
[Laughter]
so let's look at some of the the grilled
cheese like inventions that he talks
about so pretty cool I might get that
yes there's a hot plate that you put in
the microwave let's be clear this is a
hundred percent harder than making a
regular grilled cheese and if you have a
microwave you haven't a oven you have an
open flame let's look at the nephew have
a microwave you have a kitchen second
maybe you live in a dorm room it seems
the most fun it's like it's like it's
like a little Inc what is it
Uncrustables or something like yeah and
then the last one so this is just a
ziplock bag oh that you put in the
toaster so our cheese doesn't melt in
the toaster oh that's cool
and something he does and everyone or
rather he doesn't do he never puts
butter on that of the girl cheese so I
don't think he's ever made a grilled
cheese the prior to make is how to but
speaking of being in every man internet
has spotted beyond target yeah how do we
feel do we think this is a stunt funny
about this to me honestly is how you can
click the photo she's been to multiple
turns yes this is frozen 2018 the stuff
it is better it's more target the other
outfit the other outfit if you go back
it looks like she's gonna work on like a
really fancy car do you ever jumpsuit
[Applause]
and now jumpsuits are bad for like the
poor cashier that has to try to sell her
like a target car is like get her to get
that gun I would freak yeah I would say
I wouldn't respect her privacy I
wouldn't because she's asking
[Laughter]
target which I go to every day on the
prowl what are you what's a target
outfit is I'm gonna actually buy clothes
[Laughter]
we got one show this week I'm bringing
it all and this is a very nice flannel
feel this feels like I could blend in
easily at a Starbucks Starbucks plans to
install needle disposable boxes in some
bath I think because people are using
are like using heroin Starbucks
bathrooms and now there's a way to do so
they want something to know the workers
are like we keep finding blood and
needles in the bathroom we don't want to
clean this up because of obvious and so
then they were like deeper they report
yes cooties adult cooties yeah they
reported it to their manager and then
Starbucks was like okay workers we
respect you not wanting to clean this up
so now we're going to install these just
disposable
it's like someone shits on the wall and
someone she peed it's like I don't think
you're putting a box for the needles
that no one no one's hitting the toilet
their biggest problem have you guys ever
treated yourself and gone to a Starbucks
bathroom in the suburbs has ever treated
yourself and tried heroin it's like
going to a Starbucks bathroom in this up
chasing that high speaking of joy
everyday you can catch us on Twitter on
extra damn day where we talk about
what's trending on Twitter every day and
I want to shout out and say thank you so
much for a special guest she's got a
great show called its Christie bitch at
Joe's Pub on a Wednesday January 16th
you can get tickets at Joe's Pub calm
and you can catch Christie on Twitter
and Christie cello
[Applause]
[Music]